Thank you.
Hello?
Hey man, I'm just, I'm setting it up here.
I --
Hey, let me just --
Yeah, go ahead.
Try to get my audio --
Sure.
For some reason, I thought that you were -- you had a different account.
So I may have invited someone completely strange, but it doesn't matter.
I don't know why.
I always thought that you were the Don Draper account for some strange reason.
I mean, maybe.
It's possible I have more than one account.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm just trying to figure out how to get my -- the audio to come through my headphones,
if it's okay to take a minute here before we --
Yeah.
Yeah, of course.
Of course it is.
And we'll just cut off the beginning portion of time.
Hey, Sally.
Yeah, it'll be fine.
So we're going back to the beginning.
We're doing like a broad overview that we never really did before.
And Matt is helping me put that together.
All right.
It's not working, but I think it'll be okay.
You can hear me fine, right?
There's no, like, extra --
Yes.
Yeah, I can hear.
I can hear you fine.
Cool.
I mean, I -- my air conditioner is like, you know, it's old school.
It's in the window.
So it makes a ton of noise.
So I'm not going to have -- the window's open.
And you know, who only knows what they're on the street are going to do.
Yeah.
So this is like a --
Raphael's edition.
We're not polished.
Yeah.
We're not Joe Rogan.
So if something comes through the background, it'll be fine.
It'll be, you know, our regional flair.
All right.
That sounds good.
Cool.
So do you want -- are you ready to get started then?
Yeah, absolutely.
Okay, great.
So, well, thanks for having me on.
And I'm happy to provide some structure and interviews.
So I think we'll start with just what -- what is Peak Mind?
Like, what is -- what is this podcast?
I'm T and that's Matt.
Peak Mind is our new -- okay, so Peak Mind is the new podcast.
I'm not -- I'm going to cut this part off, Matt.
I'm going to start over here.
Okay, so Peak Mind is not me.
It's the period that we've been living through.
It represents the peak attention.
The period of peak aggregate attention directed through technology
to the same basic archetypes, the same basic series of events,
facilitated through social media.
So social media and technology in general is a projection, reflection,
or extension of human potential.
And in the case of social media and computer technology provides a reflection.
It provides a window into human consciousness.
And during the period that we've just lived through, we went through a period where there was a peak amount of attention directed in the same places each day across the globe.
And that event cohered reality.
That event, in a sense, solidified reality into a coherent set of patterns from an archetypal perspective.
And it's during that period when it became possible to have this process of awakening that is occurring right now among some people on the planet.
And Peak Mind as a podcast is going to discuss all different types of topics related to this event, related to the period that we have lived through and how it connects to the changes in some but not all people's awareness.
Cool.
So Peak Mind just means like, it's like the window into what everybody's paying attention to.
So everybody, it's like a time where everybody's paying attention to a small set of topics.
And it's sort of unique to this time period more so.
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, yeah, I mean, it's like not small from an individual perspective, right?
Because we're talking about millions of topics, but we're talking about the period in the history of the universe that we, as we understand it, with the most focused and sustained attention facilitated through the use of social media technology.
The same images, the same apps, the same programs, the same programs, the same games.
So limited, as in like limited compared to infinite.
And this was discussed, this is, at some point we'll do a space on Terence McKenna and Time Wave Zero, where he anticipated this, Time Wave Zero, he anticipated this series of events.
So the period, sort of Peak Mind period would be roughly late 2012 to 2019.
But we're emerging from that period right now and moving into a different form of consciousness.
Cool.
That's interesting.
Yeah, I remember you talking about something like this in 2012.
So I guess we can move on to, well, what is the revelation of the hierarchy?
We're going to talk a lot about clairvoyance, claircognizance, clairvoyant movements historically.
We're going to look at data sets.
We're going to look at history.
We're going to look at scientific research to some extent.
And we're going to look at sort of a new people, extreme populations and their perspectives.
But we're going to talk a lot about clairvoyance and clairvoyant communities throughout history.
And the data, the consistent data that they've sort of generated.
The revelation of the hierarchy is a prediction.
I mean, you could call it a prophecy, but we'll call it a prediction that came out of the last major clairvoyant community.
It's called theosophy and theosophy began in the 1860s when Western Europeans arrived in Tibet for the first time.
And ostensibly, according to their story, studied and translated esoteric Buddhist texts and brought the information from the esoteric Buddhist texts back to the West and began the theosophical clairvoyance community.
Which was very highly influential at the time that still exists, and it's still influential amongst a certain small demographic.
But it peaked from a clairvoyant perspective in the 1920s, 1930s, and it peaked with this prediction of a series of events that would take place early in in the millennia right now in 2025.
2026 and onward specifically.
Theosophy is largely forgotten because they are controversial, and they're controversial because they were sort of the 1920s version of edgelords.
They went heavy with using terminology like Luciferianism, and they did that as part of their 1920s version of edgelordism where they were revealing that the real secret of the name involved, in this case, Lucifer.
Lucifer, but was, you know, light bringer and how the esoteric community is really this secret community that's designed to enlighten humanity through the ages.
Now, as you can imagine, there was a religious pushback and because we go through cycles in our society, cycles where religion has less to do with public affairs and then cycles where it has more to do with public affairs.
And from that point forward, amongst a lot of researchers in like the conspiracy, conspiratainment industry and southern evangelicals have largely demonized the entire theosophical society.
I'm not pro-theosophical society.
What what what I'm talking about today with the revelation of the hierarchy is that the prediction that they made seems to have been accurate.
That prediction was that in 2025, an interstellar comet would enter the inner solar system and it would pass through the solar system and pass by Earth.
And that on our level that they use terminology similar to dimensions, which is sloppy terminology, we'll discuss it in a future podcast, like what interdimensional really means.
That this interstellar body would appear to be a comet to us, but on a higher dimension, I think they said the fifth dimension, and again, it's a sloppy idea, but we'll discuss it enough in a future podcast.
There would be a being involved, and that being was a promised Hindu avatar, because again, they were, they were and are esoteric Buddhists.
But they also touched a lot on Hinduism because there's a strong correlation and connection.
And this avatar is called Kalki, K-A-L-K-I, and that on the this fifth dimensional level, this interstellar object would be an avatar.
And the purpose of it penetrating and passing through our solar system would be to send a transmission to Earth.
That they referred to as his word, but reflects the concept of like some kind of signal being transmitted to planet Earth, which is weird.
Correlations are often drawn in esoteric communities between the Kalki figure in Hinduism and a figure found in the Book of Revelations, because in the Book of Revelations, there is a rider on a white horse dressed in red.
And that's exactly how they would describe the Kalki avatar.
And that rider emits a sword, again, this is metaphorical, from, from its mouth or his mouth and slays the nations.
That there's a transmission or some sort of message that this figure in the sky brings that leads to a general collapse amongst societies and civilizations here on planet Earth.
Something like a reset.
From the esoteric perspective, and again, the theosophical society edgelords, though they may be, or though they may have been, were the most recent representation or representatives of a very long 2000 plus year series of communities.
From their perspective, once this occurred, there was going to be a series of large changes in human civilization related to, you know, nations and, and governments and an event referred to as the revelation of the hierarchy.
The revelation of the hierarchy is, is, is a, is a twofold event.
And the first part of that event is the revelation of the gods, little G, the return of gods, little G, at least into human consciousness.
And, you know, these interpretations, they're very edgy.
It's a, these beings, what they would call gods, we refer to them as archons.
And it's, um, it's a, you know, these interpretations, they're very edgy.
Um, it's a, these beings, what they would call gods, we refer to them as archons.
And it's, um, a, a sort of a pivotal, um, idea, sort of a fundamental, a fundamental idea to the, the topics that we discuss.
The second part of the revelation of the hierarchy was the revelation of, um, or would be the revelation of an internal system of governance among human beings, as opposed to an external system of governance.
As opposed to, uh, presidents, kings and queens, votes and dictators.
That there was, um, an internal unconscious system of government or governance amongst human beings.
And that this, um, system would also come to light.
So an example of this system would be, for instance, Buddhas or, um, Maharivas in Jain tradition.
We're in East where you had these, uh, spiritual leaders, like the Buddha, who was born with the option of becoming a king on, you know, an external king.
Or to become a spiritual leader, which from the perspective of these communities, esoteric communities, spiritual leaders, Buddhas, et cetera, are the actual leaders or rulers of this planet, mankind, humanity, however you want to put it.
So the revelation of the hierarchy would be the revelation that there's basically the revelation of UFOs, of aliens, extraterrestrials, in some sense, levels of, of, of life and governance above and beyond us in this physical, or what we perceive as the physical world, the soul system.
And, and further out, capped by beings that once were considered to be gods and the internal revelation that humanity has, um, has a network that governs our interactions with each other and with them behind the scenes.
That's the revelation of the hierarchy.
And that's what they predicted would happen in beginning in 2026.
following the visitation of an interstellar object into the inner solar system.
Okay.
So sort of what I, what I'm, what I'm getting out of this is over the course of, of human history, there's this undulating pattern.
That's kind of like progressively more, um, not sure the right word, but, but there's a progression to the amount of awareness.
of awareness in the collective, right?
Right.
Where it goes up and maybe it goes up for a while, but then it kind of goes back down for a little while, like peaks and troughs.
But overall, if you were to take a step back, you'd see like, uh, you know, a gradual progression over time, even though it's undulating, maybe like locally.
Right.
And there's this, uh, prediction from this.
Theosophical group that predicted some interstellar comment or something coming into the solar system.
Um, that would be the mark of this next like reset where there's some kind of, um, transition from external governance to internal governance and a return of God's little G, which, which we talk about as, as like the archons.
Is that like a good, yeah, no, that's, that's very, that, yeah, that's, that's a very close.
Um, I admitted, I guess a key detail.
Um, you're correct that there's undulations in consciousness.
Uh, it is not progressive.
It's, there are different cycles.
So there are undulations in periods of millennium or millennia.
Right.
And then there are, are longer period undulations.
And, um, we are, have been on a regressive, uh, period.
Okay.
Um, and that is what's supposed to change.
Um, and as far as the, uh, external internal, uh, what.
Uh, what in fact would happen is there's going to be a period where there seems to be, um, added layers of external hierarchy.
So basically what they were predicting was what we would consider to be the appearance of, or the belief in the appearance of some kind of extraterrestrial interdimensional, um, civilization that would, um, seem to be in charge.
And then at the same time, the revelation that, um, there is human beings do actually have a network, uh, an organization that isn't part of that external hierarchy.
So, but very, yeah, I mean, I, I, very close and the, the, the, the, thank you because you're helping me, um, refine what I'm saying.
Yeah.
So what, what I'm hearing you say is, um, if you were to like, look, cause I'm like, uh, I have a, like a math background.
Right.
So I, I kind of can think of it.
It makes sense to me in terms of like graphing it.
Right.
But what I'm hearing you say is like, you might look at it first, it looks like a line, but if you step back, you'd see this like, um, like sine wave pattern.
And it's kind of like going up into the right.
But what I heard you say is it's, it's, it's, it's, if you take an even further step back, there's an even bigger undulation.
That's on the order of, you know, maybe the first undulations on the order of like hundreds of years, but the second undulation, if you take another step back, there's thousand year periods of, of consciousness expanding and retracting.
And, and we've been on this downward slope for, for on the order of maybe like a thousand years that maybe is going to shift and go back up something like that.
Yeah.
Um, there's a period, uh, called the great year or Yuga cycle.
It's approximately 26,000 years that we've been in the downward period of that, of that cycle.
Um, the, the main indicator, and this is where like your science background, your math background, um, makes an interesting counterpoint because the, the, the basic principle is that technology is, is a, is an extension of, or a replication of human potential.
So during periods, when we're on a downward spiral, we're actually progressing technologically and during periods where we're on an upward spiral, um, technological, um, uh, progress halts or reverses.
But the reason that it halts and reverses is that people are developing internally as individuals and no longer need technology.
So, um, uh, the idea would be that what computers are accomplishing now are things that human beings can inherently accomplish without computers.
But during this period of time, when we're stunted, when we're limited, the only way that we're capable of accessing that part of our nature is through these externalized objects that we create.
Is it just so a good, yeah.
So, okay.
Here's a great example.
Right.
Before we move on to the next question.
Um, telepathy.
Okay.
The, the, depending on the degree that you believe in telepathy.
All right.
Um, in a world where telepathy is conscious as opposed to unconscious, there's no need for a computer worldwide web.
The worldwide web exists telepathically.
It exists in, in dreams, right?
Like in a, in an Aboriginal society or in a, a spiritual order throughout history, right?
Like the, the way they communicated with different nodes, uh, ostensibly, if you believe them was, was telepathically.
You would need to, to use the internet to, um, to look up something happening in America, right?
If you're clairvoyant, you could do it directly through the use of clairvoyance.
So there's like a, there's like an opposition between, um, this internal, external, what we're able to do inherently versus what we need some other, something outside of ourselves to accomplish.
And when we are, um, um, developing internally, spiritually, we rely less on something outside of ourselves and we need technology less.
So there's a, there's a regression in the development of technology.
Whereas when we are less reliant on our internal selves, we are, we need our tools.
We need the things that are outside of us more.
And there's advances in technology, something like that.
Yeah, correct.
And the, the technology itself exists to provide us with, um, uh, something to focus on our attention on something tangible, visible to us that demonstrates our capability.
So technology itself serves as a mirror for human potential and when we don't see it within ourselves, we see it in objects around us.
Cool.
So I guess we can, we can move on to the, to kind of a key question here, which is, uh, do we live in a simulation?
Yes, we definitely live in a simulation.
Um, there, a number of, um, when the idea started to spread and it, it began to spread a lot earlier than most people realize.
Uh, so the simulation hypothesis is, um, uh, is credited to a man named Nick Box, Bogstrom, Bogstrom, Bogstrom.
Um, okay.
Um, I'm sorry.
Sometimes, uh, names are, are tough for me.
And particularly when I'm, when I'm in a situation where I'm trying to remain coherent, I'm sort of connected.
Right.
And at those times, language can be difficult.
It's just a little thing.
Nick Bogstrom.
Um, but the truth is, uh, the mention of the simulation goes back at least to the 1970s, Philip K. Dick,
who gave, um, a presentation in Paris, France, where he discussed the fact that we live in a quote computer simulation.
And that, um, aware people, some of whom are diagnosed with mental illness are actually more aware of changes or edits that are being made to the simulation.
I'm not making that argument.
Um, at least not here.
Uh, but so that, that the idea that we live in a simulation is at least as old as I am.
Um, but when you look at the actual roots of it, you find that early societies, uh, definitely believe that we are living in a simulation.
So, um, whether you talk about early Buddhists or early Hindus, if you talk about, uh, the Mediterranean, the, what we like to believe is hyper rational societies.
They really were not.
Um, they believed, uh, the Greeks believed that we, um, we, we don't live in the real world.
The real world was on the other side of the black sun, whatever that was.
Um, I've been told the Mesoamericans had a clear idea of, of simulationism, but I've only been told that by someone who, who, uh, claims that they're an expert, but I don't know.
Um, definitely we have a history, uh, we have it in records of myths and legends, but we also have it, um, in, um, the, the history of the evolution of these clairvoyant, um, organizations, these, uh, religious, uh, sects.
And esoteric communities that have sort of always existed side by side, or at least about 2,500 years ago, years or so, maybe longer existed side by side with normal, with normal, with regular society.
Um, we definitely live in a simulation and, uh, rather than being a computer simulation, a purely computer simulation, it's, um, it's a simulation based on a biological hardware.
Um, uh, a set of networked brains, minds, and it's the actual root of what young saw as the collective unconscious.
So the collective unconscious that speaks to us through dreams and through drawing our attention to certain imagery, um, that inventors use, um, they come up with a lot of their inventions.
Um, when people have prophetic dreams, um, when people have prophetic dreams or when they have dreams that explain problems that they're having in their life that, that seem to come from someplace else.
Um, all of that traces back to the collective unconscious, which is actually, uh, a network group of individual minds.
So the simulation exists and it's, it's very similar or more similar to a matrix scenario than it is to a computer video game.
Okay.
And so if, if we take that, we live in the simulation, then who are the archons that we alluded to earlier?
Well, how do they fit into the simulation?
Uh, the archons, the, the archon is a, well, archons mean rulers.
Uh, that's the, what the word literally means.
So there were rulers in ancient Greece that were referred to as archons.
But as time went on and, um, the, uh, philosophies that were more overtly simulation has spread through the, the middle East and the Mediterranean area.
Um, archon came to represent, uh, the planets and the rulers of the, um, the planets, the traits in human beings that the planets represented.
To, uh, people at that and the rulers of those planets.
So an archon was, um, like Mars was an archon, but in the ancient mind, there were people that lived on other planets.
That's an important distinction.
Like, uh, modern ufology, um, and people who have debates about, um, the existence of non-human intelligence believe that the idea that life exists on other planets is a modern idea.
It's not.
So the idea was that the, the planets had an influence on human lives, but there were also individuals associated with those planets that we call the gods or that were called the gods, little g at the time.
And they had, um, principalities, they had kingdoms of, uh, conscious beings associated with those planets who serve them.
Um, so extraterrestrial, extraterrestrial messengers and things of that nature.
Now, how accurate each of those beliefs were, like, I'm not making the claim that those were all accurate beliefs.
Um, but that's what an archon is and the archons themselves, um, show up or begin to show up, um, in, in clairvoyant communities and the predictions that they make.
And again, particularly in the predictions of the theosophical society that said that, um, the existence of these archons would become, uh, overtly recognized around this period right now, around the period of, of 2026.
Okay.
So the archons, they are the planets, but they're also the rulers of the planets.
And that's what's an idea.
Yeah.
It's an idea, right?
An idea that aligns, uh, different things with the same effect.
So, um, the original Gnostic conception of the archons, uh, were beings that hijacked humanity.
Uh, beings that put us into a simulation.
And when they put us into a simulation, they endowed us with certain character traits, certain instinctual behaviors that had not previously been part of our nature.
So we were one way, the archons hijacked us.
They put us into a simulation and then they gave us these vices.
And those vices, uh, are represented by the effects of the, or were projected.
Again, technology is a projection, right?
So the, the, the patterns of behavior that we refer to as vices exist within us.
To a large degree, those patterns are transpersonal.
We can't directly perceive them.
Um, but they govern how we interact with ourselves and with each other and the world around us.
Um, we, in order to become consciously aware of those patterns of behavior, uh, we project them on the planets.
The, the, the, the planets have regular patterns of movement.
And because of that, we're able to use the regular patterns of movement to take snapshots, metaphorically speaking, of what happens when a planet is in a certain place.
And over time, um, they were able to develop a way of predicting the influence of these transpersonal patterns of behavior on human beings that we couldn't directly perceive.
And so because using the planets as a mirror to, to, um, to view aspects of our own nature that we were unable to see directly, they projected that on them, right?
They projected those patterns on them and said that the planets rule the behaviors of our lives, right?
The planets cause us, Mars causes us to become aggressive.
Um, but what actually was happening was they were just using Mars as a, as a, as a way of, of looking at us by, um, using its regular period, um, of movement around the sun as a way of tracking the pattern of aggression and human interaction.
Um, at the same time, the, the, the archons that supposedly kidnapped us and put us in the simulation, um, they, they were actual beings.
And so there's a correlation between the beings who, who supposedly did this right.
Great simulation, the behaviors, they, they programmed into us, which is the purpose of the simulation and the planets, which are the projections.
Of those behaviors in the, in the minds of the ancient people.
Okay.
So if, if those are the archons, then, then what are, who are these, uh, uh, petries?
I'm not sure if I'm saying that right.
Sorry.
Yeah.
I'm not sure if you're saying it right either, because it's, um, it's a Hindu term.
And, uh, I'm pretty bad with like English words.
Nevermind.
Uh, we're in foreign terms.
So the, one of the differences, um, I think we like to, okay.
So we, we tend to believe that Western history is more well-preserved and more rational than Eastern history.
It's part of our cultural bias.
It's really not the case.
And, uh, there are issues with the historical record in the East, but they, um, they didn't go through the same number of periods of, um, religious based purification.
When, um, knowledge was, uh, purged, uh, to support, uh, the people's current at that time, uh, religious consensus consensus.
Okay.
So, um, because of that, there's more information available in East about, um, about the origins, like about simulation ism about the origins of human consciousness and the illusion of the world around us.
Um, Petri's, it seems to be an idea that exists in, um, in Hinduism of divine ancestors.
And it ties closely to the, the Yuga cycle, the great year cycle, and these periodic resets, wherein the divine ancestors, uh, are reborn every so often long periods of time to reset.
To reset, um, reality basically to reset the simulation.
And it is our contention.
Uh, we don't want to appropriate anyone's culture, but it is our contention that the existence of the concept of the Petri's is an example of the memory of the original individuals placed into the simulation.
Um, so, um, instead of being, or the, while they look at them as divine ancestors, um, we might look at them as the original individuals involved in the original consciousness and personalities involved in, in the simulation.
Um, so the individuals whose aggregate, um, minds create the collective unconscious.
So if we were going to divide the collective unconscious, say that beyond a certain line, um, on the other side, in the Unus Mundi, the one world, what we call base reality, um, is, is the collective unconscious we experience here, a collective unconscious there.
And at that point it's divisible into individual personalities because there are real individuals involved.
So those would be the Petri's in my, in my interpretation.
So in that, um, tradition, would that mean that the, the Petri's are always among us or that there are periods of time where they are not, and then they're born in, or are they like, is it part of society?
Or is it like, how, like, when do they come and, and, and, and are they always here with us?
So, um, there's this, I guess it's a meme.
Um, but it's an idea that's, that's floated around every maybe five years on the cover of a magazine that discusses the, the correlations between the universe and a neuron in a human mind.
Like structurally, there are structural correlations between what we, what we think the universe is shaped like and how it acts.
And what we think a human neuron is shaped like and how it acts.
And so there'll be magazine covers that will say something like, uh, the universe is a human mind or a human brain.
They use the term mind and it's distancing language because they, what they really mean to say is the universe seems to operate the way we believe, uh, a brain operates.
And that's a, a real thing that happens.
I would consider it to be an emerging archetype.
Um, but it's, it's, it's real ideas that come individual researchers that, you know, make a media splash that, that, um, that end up with the create a headline that sort of disappears.
And then five years later, someone else will talk about roughly speaking, this is an idea that exists in, in ancient traditions as well.
And in some modern traditions, for instance, the Sufi tradition, which is a, an esoteric form of Islam.
Uh, their primary idea is that we all live in one being, one person, the universe is a person and we live inside of it or him or whatever.
Um, the traces back to, uh, Zoroastrianism, the root religion in the Mideast that comes, comes out of Iran, which talked about, um, this idea of this original atom.
Um, and that the whole universe is basically, is basically his dead body.
Um, according to the, the myth.
Um, so this idea that everything around us is part of a, or is, is, is, is, is an expression of a physical being that we can't directly see is very old.
It's very commonly in esoteric traditions and in, um, religions as they originate.
Um, so from perspective, uh, then on here, um, you asked analogies.
Yeah.
So, um, from this perspective where you talk about simulationism, um, on biological hardware, you know, it's mixing metaphors to explain it, explain it like that.
It's basically using an interface between computers and biological bodies and technology.
Um, the, everything is, is mind from this perspective.
Um, the universe that we perceive is a model that is created inside the minds of these individuals.
The same way, like modern neurology might say the universe that you and I perceive is a model created inside our minds, inside our brains.
What we're saying is, is that in fact, it's a model created inside another brain.
Basically where, uh, a, a fragment of an individual consciousness as opposed to a full individual consciousness.
So yes, they're always here because here is them, but as a personality, as a distinct individual, as an individual aware of themselves, uh, no, they're not.
So what ancient philosophy and ancient religion seem to indicate is, or seem to talk about when they, when they get esoteric is that these, these personalities are lost here.
And that the process of awakening, um, really relates to those personalities awakening to their own identity.
Um, so they're out there like the, the individual, um, identity, but they're, they're not aware of themselves.
They're, they have no memory, just like we have no memory, um, of anything that occurred prior to what we perceive as our birth.
Um, but yeah, they're, they're, they're probably there.
Like you might be at a seven 11 and the guy behind the register might be one of the individual original individual personalities of somebody, um, involved in the creation of the simulation.
Yeah.
Um, so they are like always with us.
It's not like they, we have periods of time where they're all born.
And then there are periods of time where none of them are here.
They're like coming in and out all the time.
Yeah.
I mean, so, so when you get into the internal map of the simulation, it seems as if there are more quote dimensions, um, to it than the visible dimensions, which seems to be where the idea comes from of like multi-dimensionality and interdimensional beings, et cetera.
There seem to be parts of the simulation that of which we are not consciously aware at this time, and they may be there wherever there may be.
So, for instance, no one knows how much of what we perceive to be the universe, the simulation encompasses.
It's possible that it encompasses all of the universe.
And that's the craziest of all potential answers to the question, because that would mean that potentially there could be billions or trillions of other planets full of life out there.
And we could have, uh, God knows how much consciousness or how many individual, seemingly individual consciousnesses recreated in one simulation.
That seems excessive, but it's quite possible that what, when we look at the universe around us, like at least this solar system is part of the simulation, in which case there could be other nodes of life within this solar system.
What we perceive to be the solar system, right?
Or there could be realms like heaven and hell.
So in the ancient world, they, they would often, when they would draw out their cosmology, their conception of the universe, it would often have like a tree in the middle of it.
And then it would have a number of planes of existence.
Um, this was prior to them being referred to as dimensions.
So one common number was like nine.
Um, and there was definitely a correlation between the planets and those planes of existence.
So it is possible that those individual consciousnesses are, are whole someplace else in the simulation that we don't directly perceive, but probably, yeah, probably they're here, but they're always a part of the simulation.
And that's, that's, that's something that we'll probably discuss in like a much later, um, episode that, that may be a fundamental problem, not for us, but for the individuals involved in, in creating the simulation itself.
Like, uh, uh, the reoccurrent, um, self-awareness historically of those individuals may be something that they want to fix from their perspective.
Okay.
And so, uh, moving on to the next question, uh, what, what is the tripartite nature of man?
Uh, tripartite nature of man is a Gnostic term, um, that described the ancient conception of, uh, humanity as, um, three types of human beings existing together.
Um, the concept was, or is that, um, very similar to the modern concept of the NPC, where the levels of consciousness between individual, what would appear to be.
So what's, what's complex about this is that it's all based on appearance, right?
Cause we're really all existing in the same biological network.
So the tree outside my window appears to be separate from me.
And this is where the esoteric idea of like the illusion of separateness comes from, right?
Like there's a tree that I'm looking at right now through my window and that tree seems to be separate from me.
But in reality, as, as we believe that we believe to be reality, that tree is not separate from me.
We're, we're both existing.
We're both images generated on the same set of neurons, right?
So, um, the tripartite nature of man says that the people that you encounter in your life have different levels of consciousness.
That there are basically three types of people and the base level person is, is called a hyalic, the hyal.
This is the ancient term.
Um, obviously it's, it's not one that we have now and definitely out of favor in our time because of our, our ideological.
Um, our ideological belief in universalism, right?
Was a, it is a, um, it is something we're all indoctrinated to believe, uh, at a very early age that, or at least we were when I was younger, that all differences in people are just appearance.
And that within them, everyone is the same.
That's not what the ancient people believed.
What the ancient people believed is that, uh, there are some people who have very little consciousness.
Um, they are conscious only of themselves.
And some people would hear that and say, well, only all people are conscious only of themselves.
And that's not true.
But if you have only ever been conscious only of yourself, then it's true for you.
Um, and that type of person is called a, a hyalic.
There are psychics.
And that's where the word psychic comes from.
Um, in the ancient world, a psychic wasn't someone with a bandana on their head who read tarot cards.
It was a type of person who was conscious of the existence and the connection with the world around them.
They were conscious of this idea that beneath the facade of separateness, there was an underlying unity to, to everything.
And because of that, they had, um, extra sensory perceptions.
And then there's a, a rather rare type of person, uh, called a, a pneuma, pneumatic.
And it means, um, now pneumatic now means like, uh, uh, brakes on trucks and pneumatic because they use air.
And it means like a blown in person.
So a pneumatic person would be the individuals with the strongest identity connection to the Petris, to the divine ancestors, to the sleepers, dreamers, right?
That would be the person that might be, uh, a direct identity.
It might be the actual original personality of that individual.
And those are the called pneumatics.
So, um, we've recently found, and this will be the subject of another, um, podcast, but we've recently discovered that there is, um, well, not we want to say we, right?
Like I read about someone else discovering it and I say, wait, so, um, the Institute of Noetic Sciences, um, working with Dean Radden,
who was part of the original, um, remote viewing program as a researcher have, uh, discovered, um, a genetic mutation, uh, that about 40% of the population has.
That seems to correlate with a, with a complete lack of psychic ability or a complete lack of perception of psychic ability.
So there does seem to be a genetic marker for what we would term to be a high, like a person who is only conscious of themselves directly and is, is unable to be conscious of others directly, um, and, uh, interconnection.
So what's interesting about that is, and again, this will be a subject, you know, I don't want to digress too much, but when you look at the spread of this genetic mutation, you look at the actual epicenter of the spread.
So you can map out the prevalence of the mutation in society on a geographic basis and then trace back where the mutation began, right?
Because the closer you get to where it began, the higher the prevalence, um, in the population, the epicenter of the spread of that mutation.
And so if you go back to the beginning of this whole thing, if you go back thousands of years to the Roman empire, what made the Roman empire, it seems genetically distinct from other peoples was the presence of a mutation in this population that rendered a certain number of people incapable of having any type of psychic experience.
And thereby fundamentally materialistic, fundamentally only believing in the mechanical workings of the universe around them.
And if that mutation began around or prior to the birth of Jesus Christ, then history as we know it is shaped by the presence of that mutation because it seems that that mutation, um, would be overrepresented.
Based on the 40% based on the 40% prevalence in the population amongst people in positions of authority.
So while it's 40% of people in the population, depending on, you know, whenever you encounter authority, if you're talking to, uh, from the lowest level, like a police officer, that's not low.
I respect police officer.
I respect police officer, what I'm saying, like hierarchical, right.
Um, from your like first encounter with authority, starting with say the police or teachers in school and going up into lawyers and doctors, physicians, academics, experts in universities.
And, um, um, business leaders and politicians and possibly even aristocratic bloodlines.
But we don't know that for certain, but as you right.
And if we climb the social hierarchy, there's a strong, it seems that there may be a stronger representation of the mutation that makes people incapable of having direct psychic experience.
So the structure of the modern world, like remember I was saying that this technology exists as a projection to make us aware of facets of ourselves.
So basically without meaning to gaslight everyone, because they only know the universe they experience without meaning to gaslight everyone, the core central authority in, in the modern world, um, are projecting their lack of belief and understanding about paranormal experience.
So the fundamental assumption is that everyone else is crazy or poor or caught up in some kind of cult and, um, and these perceptions are all false, but the truth seems to be that on a basic biological level, the people who make those distinctions are, are blind.
They are missing a sense, right?
So we call it extrasensory perception because for the researchers, it is extrasensory.
But for the majority of people who happen to be disproportionately represented amongst the poor, um, on this planet, in my opinion, right?
Uh, it is not in fact extrasensory.
It is not in fact like, uh, in the study is a basic part of everyday life.
So that's the type of tripartite nature.
We, we presently, as part of our Kali Yuga stage, as part of our, our downward stage, right?
That's where the people who are incapable of having direct second experiences are overrepresented in authority.
Um, so that's, what's happening right now.
And that's the tripartite nature.
However, right.
We'll, we'll, we'll talk about that.
You know, let me cover it now.
We'll just erase it from the list of questions.
People will say, um, is it dehumanizing to call someone an NPC?
It is.
Any word can be dehumanizing based on how it's used.
So most slurs, most words used in hate begin as categorical, um, uh, words that categorize certain sets of traits.
And those sets of traits, that's nature.
That's, that's just a, I mean, there are some birds with, with blue feathers and some birds with red feathers.
Right.
Um, however, because human beings are, are iconic, we have these, these traits.
Um, we probably didn't start with these negative traits.
And one aspect of that is that we have, um, a lot of hate and negativity for other people.
And when you start categorizing people, um, though the categorizing itself, the categories, the, the definitions, the differences may very well.
The use of that term provides an opportunity for somebody else to express their hate.
And so you find this with, with language around like, for instance, racial groups in my lifetime, the official appropriate word to call black people is the official appropriate word now as black people, but it was not when I was younger, you could offend someone by using the term black people.
And so whenever we look at someone who's older and uses a term racially that, that offends us, we have to first ask, right?
The question people don't ask is, was that the appropriate term or was it a slur when they were younger?
Because oftentimes it may be a slur they've used their entire life, but oftentimes it may have been the appropriate term when they were 20 years old and they themselves just haven't adapted or stopped adapting after a certain number of reiterations of changing language in order to distance, distance ourselves from the hatred people feel for each other.
So any word, any word, any term can be appropriated by people and used for hateful purposes.
And if we have a group of people that, that others project negativity on, right, or want to take advantage of, or, or feel a revulsion towards because of some sort of biological reaction, behavioral, behavioral immune reaction that people sometimes have, which doesn't excuse it, but it doesn't excuse its expression, but it's biological in nature.
Right.
Then it doesn't matter what you call that group of people, that term will come to connotate negativity, right?
Because it's a, it's a reflection just like technology is a, is a reflection of our nature, right?
The words, the emotional value that we use, that we place on words also reflects our, our true nature as individuals or as, as,
communities of individuals, right?
So not all of us are hateful towards people who are different, but a significant number of people are hateful towards people who are different.
So those people, no matter what we call them, those words are always going to come at some point to refer to, to hateful, um, uh, to be hateful.
And so if you say like, can the term NPC be dehumanizing, I'm sure.
I think in this case, it's the very sensitized, very liberal people getting ahead of themselves.
Like I've never heard anyone say the term NPC with the tone of hatred.
I've never heard anyone, um, uh, try to lobby another person to discriminate against someone because they call that person an NPC.
I do not believe it is a hateful, dehumanizing term.
I believe it's a, it's, it's the modern version of Hylak.
I think the reason that we know psychic and pneumatic now, but we don't remember Hylak is for that same purpose or the same reason.
I stopped people, you know, it probably became, um, a derogatory term at some point.
I don't know.
It's, it's, it's a very old word.
Um, the reality is that we all exist.
We as present individual, individual identities as personalities.
Now here all exist in the same networked biological substrate.
Whether you want to look at that as a metaphor or not, or how, how metaphorical you want to put that, right?
Whether you want to just look around us, say everything around us is a hundred percent real.
That's all there is.
But on a biological level, we're connected.
And that's true because there really aren't the barriers to interaction between cells that people think there are.
So there's biological material going back and forth between us and everything around us all the time.
But in the reality, reality is we represent it, you know, we're all dreams in the same mind.
So if some of us have a more distinct conscious identity or a greater level of conscious awareness, that should never be seen as a way, admitting that, right?
Because it's a very important topic and, and being conscious of it and having a frank discussion of it should never be seen as hateful towards people who may not have that level or aren't perceived as having that level because we're all one.
All right.
Now there's no way we can stop.
Again, we can't stop.
Like the language will shift and we'll have to use another term at some point.
All right.
But the lesson here isn't that you should be offended if someone calls another person an NPC.
The lesson is that we should all have an instinctual reaction to anyone who promotes the illusion of separateness towards other life around us.
So I just, I thought I would bring that up now because I was already on a, a role against it.
So like there are Hilux, they're 40% of the population.
No, we shouldn't hate them.
And whatever term we use for them, we definitely shouldn't, it shouldn't be a hateful term because they are us and we are them.
It's just that they are never going to be aware of the things that we're aware of.
They, they miss a sense and they're never going to, in that sense, they're disabled.
And, you know, the whole, um, in the, uh, in the land of the blind, the one-eyed man is king.
It's, it's that basic concept.
But when someone says like, what the hell is going on with our government?
What the hell is going on with the administration of this school?
What the hell is going on with those billionaires, with those business leaders?
And, and they're talking about some, um, group of individuals who cluster together, seeking authority, more than likely they're talking about a group of individuals highly overrepresented with the trait of, um, of not having extracentory perception, what we call extracentory perception.
So we're basically talking about a group of disabled individuals.
So basically if someone were to say, you know, like that group of people and you use a, a negative term for disabled individuals, it's probably not far from the truth.
And that's, that's, that's, that's, you know, I mean, without ascribing any negativity to it, when we, when those of us on the outside of the authority spectrum, look at it and question the conclusions, the actions, the plans, and the level of foresight of people inside the, um, the authority structure.
That's, that's why, because they, they don't have the perceptions that we have.
All right.
So I think that brings us well along to the next topic, which is, uh, the community of awakened beings and what exactly is that?
Yeah.
So whenever you have, um, we all get caught up in the distinction between virtue signal, the distinction between visible differentiation between, yeah.
How many times I'm going to say between, we all get caught up in the visible differentiation of, uh, individuals based on what they seem to believe that becomes the important thing to us.
And the question of whether, or what each group of people believes is literally true.
And the idea that we tend to have is that one group of people, the, the group that we associate with, what we believe is true and what everyone else believes isn't true.
And they're in trouble because they're in trouble because their beliefs aren't accurate.
Um, I'm a Christian and that's not ironic.
Um, it's not performative.
I don't think that when we get to the level of awareness and awakening, um, I think you would be hard pressed to say that, uh, that the Christian demographic, at least in the United States of America is a more aware and awake demographic of individuals and other demographics.
And I think that would be a tough case to make, there are individuals in every faith slash faith tradition, every demographic, probably not equally represented.
Um, it's probably not like a per capita representation around the planet, but they are everywhere.
Right.
And they're awakening there.
They're more awake, um, than the individuals around them.
And so we have just this de facto community of awakening individuals.
And at the center of that community are individuals who are aware of the simulated nature of life.
And that's why it continues to show up in esoteric communities, in religions, in pop media, in cults, yes, in cults too, right?
Like that's the, because at the core, there is a group of people who are aware of that, but that's the community of awakened individuals.
And so that would be some of the people that we were discussing earlier, right?
The, the Petris in their present identity, but, um, that would just generally, we just call it, I can call it the community of awakening individuals because I don't know if there's any other name for it, right?
Like if, if Buddha was alive, they called it the Sangha, but the Sangha was just what was around Buddha, right?
Um, when Christ was alive, they called it the Ecclesia, but the Ecclesia was just the community around Christ.
Um, but there is a community, a sort of a global distributed network of individuals of greater awareness than other people.
That doesn't mean that their religion is right and ours is wrong or, or anything.
Um, whatever each individual believes is the ultimate truth.
That's, that's, that's for them.
That's between them and God.
All right.
Um, oh yeah, go ahead.
I'm sorry.
Um, so, so within that, like the way I liken it to is like, uh, an organizational structure, um, human beings are inherently hierarchical.
We're inherently, um, organized.
So even if you go to a place like a prison or something, you'll find an organizational structure amongst the inmates.
Like there's the external organizational structure represented by the guards, by the employees, um, you know, by the warden, the, the therapists, the legal, uh, advisors.
But there is an internal structure of organization there as well.
So like in prison here, we call them gangs, right?
But the gangs themselves are factions in what is essentially a government and wherever you find people, that's going to be the case.
And so I think we had touched on that earlier and it's, it's, um, it's important for this discussion because when we talk about like, what is, uh, if you call someone like a, a spiritual leader, that's a disingenuous term sometimes, right?
And oftentimes you can be talking about a narcissistic con man who's taking advantage of people.
And because of the inversion, um, because of the inversion in our consciousness, I mean, if we were going to say like who the real spiritual leaders are, they're probably people that no one expects.
They're probably people that others pass by every day.
Um, but, so I don't think the term spiritual leader is, is the right, um, is the right way to look at it.
I don't think we should be looking for spiritual leaders necessarily, but we should be conscious of the fact that there is an organizational level.
Right.
Um, and that would be the, um, the community of, uh, of conscious, uh, or awakening individuals.
And so that's what I, yeah.
Yeah.
So that's what people say, like, whenever you start talking about subjects like this, the touch on, right.
You can be ironic.
If you start touching on, touching on, uh, paranormal subjects, if you start touching on, um, quote, spiritual subjects on, on awakening, right.
Like you can have different strategies for doing that without drawing the ire of the people around you without drawing a lot of negativity.
Right.
And there's, there's good reasons for the negativity, because again, there were a lot of narcissistic predators who represent themselves as being gurus and leaders only to take advantage of others.
That's some of the negativity, another part of the negativity.
It, it seems, it seems that there is something akin to an immune system reaction going on that those individuals themselves, like the narcissistic individuals, psychopathic individuals.
This is something that I've, I've begun to think about recently in the last few years.
I think that people on the, the dark triad, um, uh, people with those dark triad, uh, that's what it's called, uh, Machiavellianism, narcissism, and psychopathy, right.
I think people with those traits, uh, who have those traits more strongly than others.
I think that the reason those traits exist, the reason they're conserved, um, in the population genetically is because they act as a form of immune system against, um, against people with strange ideas.
I think that in societies, they, they work towards isolating and in some sense, eliminating individuals who try to spread new ideas.
Um, and essentially anyone who's awakened is doing that.
So I think that that's the primary purpose is to suppress knowledge of an awareness of our true situation and to suppress that from spreading, um, in order to maintain the, the social, the status quo, the, the homo, homeostasis.
So, um, whenever you start talking about this, right, people are going to say like, either you have to be performatively ironic.
You're going to make a joke out of it or show everyone that you really don't believe.
And this happens with people who like talk about UFOs too, right?
Like they're a UFO influencer.
So they got to make a point of having everyone know they're being ironic and they don't really buy into everything they're saying.
Um, that's one way of doing it, right?
Because if, if you don't have a strategy, a form of distancing language, like a level of performative irony, that's when you, you're more vulnerable.
And in this case, what we're talking about, right, the vulnerability is people being accused of a being egotistical or B, um, you know, being some sort of, um, potential cult leader.
I know it's, it's crazy, but it's true.
Like when I started running spaces, same spaces with, with, with, you know, four or five wonderful people.
Um, I had spaces with four or five wonderful people.
And I had people in other spaces referring me as trying to start a spaces cult, right?
That is, um, the negativity, uh, an opportunity for negativity from other people.
So, um, that you present when you start talking about this very important material that people have to talk about.
So I, I, to be clear, like, uh, I'm not interested in being a cult leader.
And if I was interested in being a cult leader, um, I wouldn't be very good at it, right?
Um, no, no offense.
Everyone here is great, but, um, you know, clearly I, I don't have that set of abilities.
I, I don't have the narcissism for it and the ability to manipulate people.
So, and not, not that I would want to, I look at myself as a, I know this is weird, but in life, I look at myself as, as being kind of a scientist.
I think the purpose of the simulation, it's an experiment.
And, um, because it's an experiment, like we can either be the subjects of an experiment, the unwitting participants in an experiment, or we can be, um, researchers ourselves.
So I, I approach and always have approached every, um, encounter, every relationship with a certain level of like natural science, like not, not hardcore.
I'm not, uh, you know, I don't have a doctorate and anything.
I don't, I'm not a trained scientist, but I use like the basic, you know, research and, um, experimentation.
I mean, you know, I know it sounds weird, but it's true.
Like little social experiments, nothing crazy.
Um, as part of this study of astrology, for instance, there's a lot of, um, there are a lot of experimental slash research aspects to the study of astrology.
You're always keeping track of, like once you start keeping track of someone's, um, chart, for instance, right.
You'll start to notice things in interactions with them and like social events as time goes on.
And you learn from each one of those, um, those data points.
So that's, that's, that's research.
That's a form of natural science.
Uh, I, I, I would say, yes, I'm, I'm like, I have a propensity to teach people.
Now, you know, only someone else can tell you you're a teacher, right?
I'm not a teacher in the sense of being hired by people, but that's my natural, um, inclination is to, to share information with people, to teach people information.
And I would say that from the point of the collective unconscious, those of us who like express this, um, and, and spread this awareness, I'm sort of a union organizer.
Um, and I definitely get treated like a union organizer where, you know, in moments of great crisis, uh, people are more open to what I have to say than normally, um, in the level of interaction changes depending on the events in, in people's lives.
So I would look at myself as like, uh, uh, sort of a, a science-y person, uh, sort of a teacher type of person and, um, kind of a union leader.
Uh, so that's, that's what I'm all about.
And that's why we have this podcast to spread that information from like that perspective, right?
No one is recruiting anyone for a cult.
All right.
Yeah.
I've always seen you as, uh, like a philosopher and I don't mean that in like, uh, you know, so I feel like sometimes that can be taken in like a negative tone, but I mean, I don't mean it.
Yeah, no, I think it's great.
That's how I, I see, I would see it myself.
Yeah.
Okay.
Natural philosopher.
Cool.
So, um, I just want to note that it is 315 and we have more questions and, and I, I'm happy to ask the questions.
Um, how would you like to proceed?
I'd like to try to power through them in the next 15 minutes.
Um, we're trying to like keep the recording to about, well, actually we took about, hold on.
We took like five to 10 minutes to get ready.
Um, so we're gonna, we're going to remove that.
Um, so we need to have the questions wrapped up by 340.
All right.
That sounds good.
Okay.
And I can power through it, uh, pretty quickly.
Go ahead.
All right.
Do you, so you're going to be mindful of the time or do you want, uh, yeah, I mean, we can both be mindful of the time.
You know, I get off topic.
Yeah.
All right.
Sounds good.
And the next question is, uh, what were your early experiences?
Yes.
This is an important question.
Like, um, if you have, if you're connected to the collective unconscious in some way, um, you have some sort of, uh, purpose or mission related to that here in, in this life.
More than likely you have the, uh, a set of early experiences, um, you have a very early experience of having an identity greater than what would be expected for someone that age.
So for me, the way that, that manifested was that I was always aware and critical of the adults around me from like almost an adult perspective.
Um, of, you know, watching people from a very early age and knowing that there were effects that their behavior would cause predictable effects and, and knowing that they themselves were unaware of these predictable effects.
Um, I also, um, had a sense that I had something that I had to accomplish within a period of time.
So every day of my life for the first 30 years, um, definitely for the first like 20 something years.
And then as time went on, it became less consistent, but like when I was six or seven or eight years old, like I woke up every day, every single day thinking, oh my God, another day I've lost another day.
I'm another day behind and getting what I need to do done.
Now, and like, I would think about it for half an hour or 40 minutes at the beginning of the day, every single day.
I didn't have a choice.
Um, now the, here's the thing about that though.
Right?
Like that's not, um, that's not a humble brag.
It would be a weird one if it was right.
But it's like the most disempowering thing I can possibly think of to be honest, because when you're that age, you can't do jack shit.
You can't do anything.
Right.
And so, um, having this sense that like, oh my God, I've got to do something.
I have this mission.
I've got to complete it.
I got to every day.
I can't lose another day.
Um, when you're sort of a spacey dreamy kid, particularly when you're spacey and dreamy.
And when you're in touch with the collective unconscious, because we get very spacey, right?
It's not a, um, character flaw.
It's a biological fact that, you know, spacey people and people who tend to procrastinate, their brain is operating on a level more closely to a dreamlike state.
And if you are connected to the collective unconscious on a more conscious level, that is what happens.
So your, your brain is, is more dreamlike.
You sort of dream your way through the day and everyone becomes highly critical of you for that.
But in fact, that's a sign of connection, not a sign of a character.
So, uh, I had early problems, like run-ins with, um, my parents being concerned about me having psychological problems because hold on before you jump to any conclusions, people listening, because from a very, very, this was the 1970s.
All right.
Now, I think Star Wars was the first and only movie I saw in the seventies.
So that was a factor, I'm sure, but I haven't been able to, to positively identify Star Wars as the causal issue.
I would have very vivid, uh, daydreams, um, of space, flying saucers, aliens, space battles.
And it was very difficult for me to connect with other people because I was on a different, right?
Like in a sense, developmentally different from people around me.
Um, because I had this feeling that I was an adult, right?
Dealing with people who really weren't.
Um, but at the same time, like very, you know, childish because I was a kid.
Um, but so I spent a lot of time, um, off by myself, like pretending to be a space alien in space battles.
Now that's not unusual for children today, but it was highly unusual for children at that time.
And you would, um, if you even sat around talking about rockets, they would send you to see a psychiatrist.
Like if a kid in the 1970s talked about rockets, they, they would send you to a psychiatrist.
That's, that's the truth.
Or it's a counselor or something, not a full psychiatrist.
Right.
So, um, they were concerned about me because I was like constantly preoccupied with the idea of like space battles and conquering planets and shit like that.
I don't know if it means anything except that my mind was open to the unconscious.
So I had this, a constant sense that I had some sort of mission.
Um, I would study encyclopedias and, and talk to people about railroads and in foreign countries, because, you know, we were going to have to know where the railroad, railroad was in order to take over the country.
I mean, just, uh, you know, I, I, I, I was young.
I thought I was going to conquer the world, but I was working on it.
Um, so yeah, just.
Uh, at that point you have like more imagination, I think, than most kids.
And, uh, you have this sense that you have this like daily mission that preoccupies your time.
Some people, I think who had that, like Elon Musk, people like that, they, they handle it more effectively.
I was not effective at all at that point or any point in my life.
Um, so it's definitely not anything, um, to brag about, but there is a clear difference in the early life.
There's some, like, did you ever see anything?
Yeah, a little bit, but nothing that you would differentiate from anyone else who's honest about their childhood, I think.
Um, but clearly like there was a different level of, of consciousness every day, um, that didn't fit in at all with the people around me.
Like, not just the children, but the adults either.
Um, so that, that's my answer there.
Awesome.
Uh, when did you begin to understand what's going on?
So, uh, 1993, there was a conjunction of the planet, um, Uranus and Neptune in February of that year.
It also happened, uh, in 95, I think.
It may have been three, three times.
Um, that, that conjunction rules the, um, sudden awakening, uh, to and of the collective unconscious.
There was a, for anyone who was alive during the nineties, it was sort of like a, a utopian period for, uh, quote, spirituality.
And like that type of life, like, you know, health food stores and yoga and, um, um, I don't know, things like that.
New age bookstores and, you know, new age books.
And, um, there was a bigger, much bigger part of our life than it has been ever since.
Uh, that was because of that conjunction after that conjunction, um, or during that conjunction, I became aware of Gnostic texts.
I became aware of Philip K. Dick, um, and although weed was definitely a factor, uh, we were having direct perceptions of the simulated nature of reality to one point or another.
And when I say we, it wasn't just me, there were thousands.
Um, I, myself know a dozen or half a dozen people, um, around my age to 10 years older than my age who, um, went on to like study the paranormal or, um, get involved in like starting some sort of odd thing, whatever it is, some sort of odd discipline or whatnot.
Um, and it all began at that period of time.
So, uh, the first understanding I had of, of the simulation was in 1993, 1994, um, and not just me, but other people, um, we would spend a great deal of time and energy trying to wake other people up to both the fact that like we live in a world that's somewhat simulated at least.
Um, and also that we're headed to some sort of major, uh, social calamity, right?
So that was very common.
Um, and what happened was the people who were involved in that would largely turn on each other, much like influencers today.
Um, and everyone's perception was that they themselves had sort of, uh, um, an accurate or genuine experience.
Um, and that everyone else was being egotistical or manipulative.
Um, but I would say that we've known, I've personally known, and we have known as a society that this, this was real.
Um, and this was happening since the mystical awakening of the 1993, 1994.
Okay.
Um, just for the time, we have about 15 minutes and six questions.
So yeah.
Okay.
Um, yeah.
Go ahead.
Uh, what do you say to people who claim that there is ego involved with claiming to represent a subject or group to claim greater knowledge about subjects that seem speculative?
The real ego is individuals who try to interfere.
Um, narcissists attempt to subvert systems for their personal gratification and to suppress anybody else who is, is trying to, um, trying to awaken individuals for any other purpose.
Um, cause narcissistic individuals demand that the universe serves them.
So, um, it is not ego.
Having these conversations is not egotistical.
Um, representing these topics is not egotistical.
Trying to stop these conversations, trying to stop someone from representing these topics.
That is an egotistical sign.
That is a sign that someone is a narcissist.
Okay.
Next question.
Is everyone who's awakening a member of the same community?
No, um, ideally yes, but people get stalled halfway through, um, or they get caught themselves in that ego trap and, um, they, um, begin to see everything that's going on as being about themselves.
And they get caught up in that narcissistic, trying to stop other people, um, from spreading awakening.
Like there's, if someone is spreading a bunch of shit, right, that's not narcissistic to try to stop them.
If somebody is talking about topics in general and trying to stop them from talking about those topics, that is the, the narcissism.
Uh, those individuals highly overrepresented in the influencer community are super, super influential right now.
And, um, whether they have a genuine spark of awakening or not, if they're going to work hard to suppress the process of awakening and to suppress the spread of this understanding, then they need to be, uh, boycotted.
They need to be seen as being removed from the community and not fully shunned, but not supported, uh, financially or with attention, et cetera.
All right.
What do you got?
What's the next one?
The next one is how do we connect more closely with our unconscious selves?
Dreamwork, meditation, um, cultivating the, the period between when you start to go to sleep.
And when you start to dream, the thing that people hate the most when they say like, Oh, I'm a terrible sleeper because they're not fully unconscious when they, when they're, you know, when their head hits the pillow is if you're lying there fully awake, um, then that's a problem.
But if you're in a half dream state, that's the, the period where your mind is, um, the most open to connection with the collective unconscious.
Cause that's the state cultivated by, um, by inventors, for instance.
And we're going to do a podcast on how to do that.
Um, Thomas Edison, as people probably know, would take naps in a chair with, with metal balls in his hand.
So that when he started to doze off, the ball would hit the floor and then he would wake up and remember what he'd been thinking.
Um, so dreamwork, lucid dreamwork, meditation, some meditations, but in others, we're going to talk about that in future podcasts.
So, um, the evidence began with this archaic revival, um, related to, uh, hermeticists like Alistair Crowley, a cultist that now called, they refer to themselves as hermeticists, uh, that began with the Pluto Neptune conjunction in the late 1800s.
And it's tied closely to the paranormal community and, uh, paranormal experiences.
Uh, that would be the, the event that signified the return of archons into our collective conscious, um, consciousness.
Uh, we see the, the spread of that through, um, uh, channeling, right?
Individuals came to channel, uh, entities, which is a weird topic.
We'll talk about that in other, um, in, uh, other podcasts.
Uh, they started to channel in the 1950s, a group of beings called the, and I know this is going to sound weird.
We'll talk about it in podcasts.
You know, it will be less weird, but it's still weird, but it will be less weird to you.
The council of nine of raw, which is, uh, one of the main groups connected to these channeling experiences that people have, which I don't support.
Um, who represent themselves as the returning archons, Gene Roddenberry, if you've ever seen Star Trek, you know, there are a lot of episodes that are related to the idea, the concept of archons.
And it is because Gene Roddenberry himself was, um, a regular practitioner, a member, uh, viewer of these channeling sessions and got a lot of his ideas for Star Trek from this council of nine of raw.
And that's where it's begun to spread through the media.
Um, and it's at the point now where, uh, researchers and investigators claim that there is, uh, a presence in rocket science and like NASA, that there is, um, there is a hermeticist presence in NASA and individuals involved with space research who are connected to the, the idea of these returning archons.
Diane Posolka, I think is probably the best, uh, well-known, uh, highly credentialed and respected academic who discusses these topics.
We'll talk about it in future podcasts.
Is the knowledge of the reality overlay emerging into the collective conscience?
Uh, yeah, this is huge as an emerging archetype, like the big one, I'm going to give an example here.
Right.
And one that if I had mentioned this 15 years ago, everyone would roll their eyes.
Cause I did in like 2010, I used to try to talk to people about the emerging zombie apocalypse archetype.
And I know that's weird and sounds kind of nerdy.
Um, but when an archetype is really powerful, it's taboo and no one will pay attention to it.
They'll turn it into kind of a joke.
I believe that that archetype, all those zombie runs.
I don't know if everyone remembers like around 2011, people would dress up as zombies and they go for like 5k runs through towns and shit.
Like it was a big thing.
And there were all these zombie shows, uh, that was all related to COVID.
I think the lockdowns, I think that was our collective unconscious communicating to us about the, the COVID lockdowns.
And you can see that from the imagery because the empty wasteland like imagery, um, has only ever been like in a modern sense.
Um, the only event where anything like that has ever happened in human history, um, was COVID where three fourths of the world was on lockdown and like city centers across the world were empty.
So that was that emerging archetype since that time, the main emerging archetype has been the simulation.
And so we see it in, uh, TV shows and popular franchises, like even in video games, uh, people who are video gamers will be familiar with fallout.
And fallout has been around since the nineties and they have a TV show now.
And the big reveal of the last season of the TV show was a biological based simulation, um, a head in a jar.
Um, you see TV shows that are directly based on simulationism people talking about it.
We have influencers, we have academic influencers online talking about simulationism.
We have non-academic influencers talking about simulationism, both of them making a ton of mistakes and spreading a lot of misinformation about the topic because they don't really know, um, what they don't know.
And we know significantly more about this topic than they do or anybody else.
Um, so, uh, yep.
The, the archetype is emerging and all you have to do is go on X, um, go into a space or, or turn on the TV and watch something science fiction.
And you will find simulationism.
That wasn't the case five years ago.
Um, and it's to the point now where it's like very common and it will become very common.
It will become so common.
You will hear people talking about it in coffee shops.
If people still go to coffee shops, you will have relatives who talk to you about it.
Uh, this will all be in the next couple of years.
It's the archetype is emerging right now.
All right.
And the last question is, where's the podcast going from here?
So, um, I've run a bunch of X spaces on a, on a number of topics and they've all been related to the simulationist idea.
Uh, but I don't always make that clear.
Um, mostly because I got the same wonderful people who show up for every, every, um,
for, for, for every space.
And, uh, I don't want to keep hitting them with the same 10 minute introduction every time.
Right.
I tried to formulate an introduction at one point in time.
And it sounded like something a child had written.
So I knew that psychologically, I guess I wasn't ready to formulate the right introduction or something.
Um, so I got rid of that idea.
Uh, but what I'm going to do is I'm going to take these disparate elements of spaces and put them together into a categorical framework.
Uh, something where it's coherent that each time you listen to the podcast, you recognize how it connects to the larger, um, the larger, uh, idea about, you know, simulation and awakening.
Because really when we talk about like simulation, it wouldn't mean anything if we weren't waking up to it.
And most people aren't waking up to it, but some of us are right.
So it would just be noise.
It would just be complete science fiction.
Like when Philip K. Dick was talking about, it was like far out science fiction.
People were calling him a schizophrenic and maybe he was right.
So if you, in 1974, uh, when I was born talked about these topics, people would call you a schizophrenic and maybe the people were right, but not now.
Now it's part of popular culture.
Um, and there, I don't know any schizophrenics.
Oh, well, first of all, I know very few schizophrenics.
I don't have mental health issues myself.
And, um, I have very little connection with the mental health community.
However, I haven't heard of any schizophrenic in my lifetime.
Talk about simulationism.
Uh, it's not a mentally ill idea anymore.
It's a science idea.
The people who are proponents of it are like scientists and researchers and academics and Elon Musk, right?
The richest man in history credits it to his playing the simulation game.
Um, we're going to cover those topics and, and tie it all together.
One of the reasons that I'm, instead of just making spaces and putting the word out there is that I want like things in a more accessible format.
And also I'm trying to, I'm not trying to grift.
I'm trying to monetize a little bit because I have these cats and I didn't talk about the beginning.
People who know my spaces know the cat situation where, um, when I was, um, in a wheelchair, uh, a relative abandoned a cat here.
Um, and then following that, a neighbor either died or just left and left two cats who moved into the front yard and were persistent enough about that.
That eventually more than a year later, um, might've been two years and two horrible winters, I guess.
Uh, I ended up taking care of them.
And as a disabled person, I don't have tremendous resources.
So taking care of the cats is, has become quite a challenge.
And while the podcast will not be about cats, uh, the purpose of the podcast being monetized, which is the goal would be to raise enough, just enough money to take care of the bills with the cats that I struggle to take care of.
So there will be like, um, a buy me a coffee thing.
There will be like a go fund me thing like that.
Those things will show up, but they're not showing up because I'm looking for a full income and to keep shaking everyone down.
They're going to show up because, um, that that's what I really need to, that's what I really need to do is I, I want to keep talking about these subjects.
I need to find a way to not be constantly stressed out about taking care of three sick cats.
So that's what you can expect from the podcast going forward.
Um, I mean, all right, so I, I guess that's everything.
Uh, how do you want to handle this?
Well, look, that's, um, so we hit it with three minutes to spare, right?
So I was hoping for 75 minutes and we made it in 87.
Um, that's great.
That's great time.
I mean, obviously it's the first time, right?
Um, but it's a proof of concept because if we can do this one, it's a general summary in that period of time.
We can do any of these topics in a period of time, right?
And shoot for a goal of like 75 minutes and never let it go over an hour and a half.
But because we're recording these first ones in spaces before I'm terrible at making decisions and we have other ways of recording the podcast, but I can't decide between them.
So we're just doing it in spaces because I'm used to that until, uh, because I'm acting like a boomer, right?
Until I can absorb in, in, in the best possible way.
But I love boomers and, you know, I love all people.
Um, until we can get that all figured out, I'll just, we'll just be recording in spaces.
Um, I told people that they can come forward and speak.
Uh, not that she's, that sounded terrible.
I didn't tell people they could come forward and speak.
I asked people not to request to speak until we had gotten done with the, this part of it.
And then if anyone wanted to speak, they could do so afterwards.
I, I don't see anyone here who usually wants to speak.
And, you know, because it's like a filibuster, um, you know, people move on to other, uh, spaces where they can't speak.
So, you know, it's up to people, wonderful people support Sadie and Sal and Justin.
Thank you very much for being here.
So, I mean, officially, I think it's, it's over, Matt.
I'm just going to give anyone a chance to say anything if they would like to.
And then, um, that part of it wouldn't go in the recording, but like officially it's, it's, it's a wrap.
We'll see everyone next week.
All right.
Sounds good.
Thank you.
All right.
So no one is requesting to speak.
So I'll end the, um, I'll end the space and it's going to sound more polished.
I'm going to do better.
Um, as time goes on, it will be more of a, like refined product.
Hopefully it was never going to be like these other.
People, um, who are really good at influencing and really good at like that type of thing,
but it will be better than it was.
Um, thank you for listening and for always listening and there'll be about 15 second pause for the space.